[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the u.s
is fast approaching an almost
incomprehensible point in the
coronavirus pandemic
it has killed nearly 200 thousand
americans far more than any other
country
the actual number is likely to be even
higher because not all victims have been
counted
the death toll has slowed over the
summer but fall begins tomorrow
and experts warn that another
devastating season
could be on the way our lead national
correspondent david begno
has the story
[Music]
funeral bells at the national cathedral
in washington d.c
told yesterday in remembrance of the
roughly 200 000 people killed in the
united states by coronavirus
even as the nation mourns experts are
warning
the pandemic is far from over listen to
what the former fda commissioner scott
gottlieb told face the nation moderator
margaret brennan
well i think we have at least one more
cycle with this virus heading into the
fall and winter if you look what's
happening around the country right now
there's an unmistakable spike in new
infections
large gatherings continue nationwide
like this biker rally at the lake of the
ozarks in missouri
one local health expert called it an
explosive petri dish
as tens of thousands of people arrived
over the weekend
my opinion is if i'm going to get it i'm
going to get it missouri is one of
nearly a dozen states where the rate of
coronavirus tests coming back
positive is above 10 percent and one of
20 states
where that rate is rising it is also
where frank looper lived with his family
the 67 year old was a pastor an avid
gardener
a father of five and a grandfather to
six
he died due to complications from
coronavirus on september 7th
after spending three weeks in the
hospital here's his daughter rebecca
what do you want to tell your fellow
americans
being the daughter of someone who died
from this virus how many more
needless deaths need to happen before
you are responsible and you do the right
thing by your family and your friends
those strangers walking down the street
how many more nameless deaths need to
happen
says her father fred had no pre-existing
conditions
over the weekend adeline fagan died she
was an ob gyn who died in houston texas
she had been doing rounds in the
emergency room trying to help out down
there
she fought for her life for nearly two
months she contracted the virus back in
july
and died this weekend at the age of 28.
shyla pennington was a veteran teacher's
assistant in florida she worked for
nearly two decades
with the volusia county schools they are
nearly
two they are two of the nearly 200 000
faces
and it's a reminder to all of us tony
we've been covering this story every
single day
any one of us could be one of those
victims
such an important story david this thing
is not over
thank you very much